il est trop tôt donc pour encore avoir
des informations très précises est ce
que les sentiments malgré tout parce que
la droite a joué plutôt l'unité oui sur
l'agglomération que ça va payer
oui ça a payé aux municipales et les
l'objectif c'était de prouver au cannet
aux habitants de l'agglomération qu'on
était capable de maintenir la dynamique
et que la première élection locale qui
se présentait était pas à l'écueil pour
nous est que nous maintenions ce
fonctionnement dans la majorité
j'ai connu par le passé des moments où
ce passage d'une élection cantonale
pouvait être délétères sur le
fonctionnement de la majorité et donc on
a vraiment travaillé pour transmettre ce
message d'unité et dire aux habitants
que nous étions unis parce que nous
souhaitons toujours travaillé dans
l'objectif de privilégier les habitants
la ville et nos communes
le bon signe premier tour c'est que la
mobilisation est un peu plus forte que
ce qu'on pouvait craindre
ou est-ce que ça peut vous profitez ou
est ce qu'on sait pas encore vraiment
qu'ils savent profiter
non je veux alors là je suis bien
incapable de vous dire si ça nous a
profité aux pas que je sais c'est que
les citoyens sont ne sont pas là où on
les attendait ils ont prouvé qu'ils
étaient capables de
de se déplacer y compris pour une
élection départementale qui a changé non
qui a changé de périmètre qui a changé
de mode d'élection dont on ne connaît
pas encore les compétences
définitivement et de montrer que malgré
ça le vote pour eux étaient précieux
précieux pour la république et donc ils
se sont déplacées je pense que déjà
c'est la première bonne nouvelle de
cette élection et ce qu'il craque pour
qui la présence du front national vous
pensez qu'il ya un siège plusieurs
pourraient être enlevés au conseil
général du calvados à ce que je peux
absolument pas à vous dire en l'état
actuel des choses je n'ai pas assez
d'éléments je pense qu'il ya des
secteurs dans le départements plus
ruraux où une forte poussée du front
national était envisagé jeu il n'y a
aucune raison qu'elle ne se confirme pas
très honnêtement on est d'ailleurs tout
a été fait dans la campagne médiatique
pour bien porter les choses et bien les
poussées et bien les affirmé et donc ce
qu on avait pressenti aux élections
européennes va certainement se confirmer
aux élections cantonales il y avait des
candidats partout et donc c'est un parti
qui va attirer des voix et probablement
avec une poussée remarquable à l'échelle
du département également mais comme on
va le retrouver partout en france pour
le deuxième tour j'ai déjà un appel à
aller aux électeurs qui ont bien écouté
j'attends d'abord d'avoir les résultats
seront quand on vous voyez vous parce
que je ne les ai pas pour l'instant
et puis moi je ne ne lance pas des
appels en général je vais voir les gens
personnellement je fais du porte-à-porte
je les contacte directement et c'est
dans le vis-à-vis dans la discussion aux
5 milliards qu'il peut y avoir entre des
personnes que les choses se jouent c'est
comme ça que je serai en conçoit la
politique locale
donc vous savez je suis très soucieuse
et scrupuleuse de l'indépendance des
gens et pour ça j'ai confiance aussi
dans la capacité qu'on peut avoir à
trouver un terrain d'entente sur une
élection